Rober was on board so later that week I
hired a professional tailor to help
design the chilly suit based on a
detailed sketch I had drawn the easiest
way is probably typical to Chilean I
guess from the neck part right sure
our plan was to have the Chile
reservoirs mimic the distribution of fat
on a larger man's body so it wouldn't
look suspicious under clothing and with
the help of a guy from Craigslist our
tailor was able to take all the
measurements he needed the Chile is
gonna go here we going to get it more in
here - mm-hmm you could probably do like
a cup there yeah you know copper silver
cup yeah yeah okay all right so we'll
see Roman yeah thank you so much and a
few days later we received a completed
prototype of the heat-resistant
polyvinyl chloride suit designed to hold
over a hundred servings of fresh Chile
the individual reservoirs would be
linked by a network of tubes that would
all lead to a battery-powered
peristaltic pump for dispensing the
Chile using our intake funnel we load it
in over 30 pounds of robert's product
that have been blended into a thin paste
to ensure an even flow without
compromising the flavor so with that I
activated the pump and then it was time
to see if this could work as I had hoped
the pump dispensed the Chile at a steady
pace which was good but I realized we
had overlooked a crucial detail the
Chile suit prevented bathroom access and
because of its weight removing it during
a game would not be an option so I
experimented with a design that would
allow me to deposit my excretions
directly into custom rubber underwear
connected to a secondary pumping system
so I could eject it into a toilet via a
second tube down my right arm but once I
had some clothing on I realized the
potential for a costly mix-up was too
great so I had the bottom part of the
suit redesigned with strategic holes in
the groin and buttocks region that would
allow the wearer to relieve him or
herself without taking off the suit
but there was still the issue of the
temperature to meet Health Department
standards Robert said the Chile would
have to remain above a hundred and
thirty five degrees Fahrenheit at all
times but when I put it on the heat was
so intense that I could barely have it
against my skin for more than a few
seconds
so I tracked down some heat resistant
polymer gel that could insulate the body
against the most extreme temperatures I
did a preliminary test with a blowtorch
on various parts of my body to ensure
the gel would protect even my most
sensitive regions and after getting
gelled up from head to toe the burning
sensation had completely vanished yeah
it seemed like we had solved every
problem but there was still one final
thing I had to take care of the pump on
my chest that made the chili suit
function was made out of metal and to
get into Rabobank arena every ticket
holder has to pass through a metal
detector so I figured if I could
convince security that I had a medically
necessary pacemaker they wouldn't be
suspicious when the alarm went off
so I taped a real pacemaker to my chest
and then headed to a walk-in clinic to
request an x-ray that would hopefully
trick the physician into writing me a
doctor's note I would need to actually
examine you and see why is it that you
need the x-ray I have to have a reason
why well I'm paying you for it so what
do you care I'm actually legally it's
it's being monitored do you see why
we're ordering an x-ray oh well what's
the minimum I need to say to get one
either some area hurts of your of your
chest or you're having a cough okay yeah
are you what are you experiencing yeah
both those yeah okay
and you're gonna take the shirt off okay
okay
I'm a little self-conscious about my
body would it be okay if I left at least
my undershirt up your under sure we'll
be fine
but I got to get rid of the buttons okay
okay and once the doctor saw the
pacemaker on my x-ray it looks like it's
in well position and no abnormalities
she wrote me a doctor's note that would
hopefully get me through security thank
you so much doctor and that meant it was
finally time to buy a ticket to the next
Bakersfield Condors home game
you